i do want to ask you
please about trump
uh so you're now a successful podcaster
i've talked to joe about trump uh joe
rogan
and joe's not interested in talking to
trump
it's just fascinating i try to dig into
like why yeah
uh what would you interview
uh trump on like realignment for example
and uh do you think it's possible to do
a two
three hour conversation with him where
you will get at something
like human or you get something like we
were talking about the facade
he puts forward do you think you could
get past that
no i don't i i look i was a white house
correspondent
i observed i observed this man very
closely
i interviewed him i think if that mic is
hot
he knows what he's doing he just he's
he's done this too long lex
he just knows but do you think he's a
different human now after the election
do you think that not at all i don't
i think he's been the same person since
i i really do like basically 1976
i studied trump a lot and i think he's
basically been the core of who he is
and elements of that ever since he built
that
you know the ice rink in central park
and got that media attention
that was it yeah he's a fascinating
study i still i feel
uh there's a hope in me that there would
be a podcast like
uh like a joe rogan like a long-form
pockets where something could be
you know and you're actually a really
good person to do that
where you can have a real conversation
that looks back at the election and
reveals something on us but
perhaps he's thinking about running
again and so maybe he'll never let down
that guard yes
but like you know i just love it when um
there's this switch in people where
you start start looking back at your
life
and wanting to tell stories like you
know
trying to extract wisdom and like
realizing you're in this new phase of
life where
like the battles have all been fought
now you're this
old like former warrior and now you can
tell the stories of that time
and it seems like trump is still at it
like the young warrior he is he's not in
the mode of telling stories
you know what i got from rogan he's the
only president who didn't age while in
office
it's true right like because and this is
what i mean because he lives in the
moment like the job
actually aged obama i mean i mean bush
same thing even clinton clinton was like
fat yeah
it looked miserable by like 2 000 hw
like i mean reagan famous actually yeah
pretty much everybody i think about
um yeah including john f kennedy who got
much sicker while in office
the job like weighs on you and makes you
physically ill
trump was he's the only person who just
was he didn't have to do it he almost
gotten stronger and he was one of the
most divisive
like uh the climate there's so many
people attacking him
so much hatred so much love and hatred
and it was just he's
it was i mean it was uh whatever it was
it was uh
quite masterful and and a fascinating
study
you